INSTRUCTOR: Hi,
data 2100 students.
In this week's
video, we are going
to work through
Python and SQL, using
a Python to run SQL
queries and look
at those through the lens
of inserting and updating
records of data.
So we can insert a
new record of data,
and we can update an
existing record of data.
So, as a reminder, our
Python and SQL connection
makes Python significantly
more powerful.
We can now access a large amount
of data stored in a database.
Further, we will use
our SQLLite3 module.
It's a set of classes,
functions, and variables
defined and implemented that
we can import into our Python
program and allow us to utilize
those functions, like the len
function for example.
That len function is
not a part of SQLite3,
but len is a function, but
other functions that we can use
that are part of SQLite3
to be able to run our SQL
queries in Python.
So we have our
SELECT statement--
SELECT, FROM, WHERE, GROUP
BY, HAVING, ORDER BY.
We've already reviewed
this a little bit,
but we also have our
inserting records of data
and updating records of data.
So when we're inserting
a record of data,
we say insert into
the table name,
then we list out the fields
that we want to add data to,
and then the values of
those coordinating data
values that we want
to add into field 1.
So for example, if field
1 is first is the ID,
we place the ID here
within my values entry,
this set of values.
And I say, I want to replace--
I want to add, not replace,
I want to add the ID of 3
into the ID field
and same thing.
So we have to make sure
that we list the fields
in the same order as
the values that we
want to add into those fields.
If the primary key
is auto incrementing,
we do not need to mention
the field nor the value,
and the insert statement as the
relational database management
system will automatically assign
a unique incremented field
as the primary key.
Another way we can manipulate
data stored in a database table
is by updating an already
existing record of data.
So for example, we say
update, and then we
place the table name.
We set, and this is
generally we say, set
and we place the
column name here,
column name equal to the
value that we want to change.
And then we say,
WHERE primary or WHERE
the ID equals 3 or WHERE
last name is equal, whatever.
So just make sure
that WHERE clause
we utilize that
WHERE clause heavily
in an update statement because
this specifies where we actually
want that update
to occur or if we
want to think about it as
which record we want to update.
And then finally, the
Delete is when we can change
or when we can delete a
record in a database table.
So I say delete the table
name and then maybe I'll say,
WHERE first name equals Reagan
and last name equals Sigurd.
So, for example, WHERE clause
is the most important part
of the Delete and the most
important part of the update
because if I just say
delete table name, then
it deletes my whole table.
So that's just a brief reminder.
As a part of this,
we are now going
to step into our
update examples.
So, please go ahead
and go there with me.
I'm going to click
Copy to Drive,
and then it will make
a copy within my drive.
And then I'll say,
Reagan, Sigurd--
perfect-- Python SQL
insert and update.
All right.
So down here below, we will
notice here as a reminder
that we are utilizing a
file version of our Overland
database.
We basically downloaded
the Overland database
that's on our Stairway
SQL Server, downloaded it
into a file that has a
file extension of DB.
This is literally
a whole database,
all of those database
tables in Overland in one
file that then we can
access and write programs
within our Google Colab.
So it makes it a lot easier
than having to troubleshoot
the connection to the server.
But it's the same thing.
The only thing that
would change is
you would just change
the way that you connect.
Instead of using
this connection,
you'd say, I'm actually
connecting to the Stairway
server and place your
credentials here.
So it's the same thing.
We're still running the same
types of queries, all of that.
We're just doing it
through a database file.
So I'm going to come over here
to this folder on these files,
and I'm going to
upload as well as you
upload the Overland
SQLite file so that I
can access this database.
It's going to sit
over here in my files.
So you'll notice that will
get uploaded, and here it is.
Sometimes it does time
out, so you may need
to re upload the database file.
All right.
So we are going to--
here in the Overland
database, we're
going to return Troy Jacobs
as record ID, first name,
last name, age, and ski level.
Troy's employee ID is 12324.
So let's go ahead and do this.
I'm going to first capture
this data, run this query
to return Troy's information.
So I'm going to
import this library.
And then I'm going to
just run that, make sure
it runs just fine.
That's great.
Then what I need to do next--
we've already talked about
this--
I need to create a cursor.
And a cursor utilizes--
this is similar to what we're
talking about as far as this
is a part of the SQLite3.
The cursor is going
to be named cursor,
and basically this is what goes
and runs MySQL queries for me
against the database.
Once I have that cursor
created, then I'm
going to say, cursor
to execute and I
want to execute a
SELECT statement that
shows me the record ID.
So SELECT req ID, employee first
name employee last name, age,
and ski level from employee,
where, and I want to say,
where Troy's--
so the employee ID is 12324.
4.
So I'm going to copy that down.
I'll say where req
ID is equal to 12324.
Now, if I come over here to
our Overland ERD and data
dictionary, as a reminder,
if you're still like,
oh, I can't remember what the
field names are in the employee
table, look here, the record
ID is the primary key,
employee first name, last
name, age, and ski level.
So that's what I'm
going to run here.
Once I run this
SQL query, then I
want to grab all of those
records returned by that cursor.
I'm going to fetch
all those records that
are returned by that cursor
into a list called results.
I'll say results
equals cursor.fetchall.
So I'm going to capture
all the records returned
by the SQL query.
And now I need to say for
Y in results, print Y.
So I loop through every
one of those records being
returned to me and output each
of them onto their own line.
So I'll see here that I'm
only having one record
output because I said req
ID must be equal to 12324.
And now I have Troy's
information returning to me.
So perfect.
So I returned all
that information.
I can see here that, based
upon my select query,
req ID is 12324, employee
first name is Troy,
employee last name
is Jacob, age is 24,
and its ski level is advanced.
So now, unfortunately,
it looks like Troy's age
was recorded incorrectly.
Troy is actually 33.
Update Troy's age accordingly.
So now I'm going to say,
all right, let's, again,
use my cursor.
I'm going to say cursor.execute.
And I'll say, cursor.execute
update employee set.
Right now, I need to
set the age equal to 33.
Don't run this
because I need to say
where the req ID is equal to
Troy's req ID, which is 12324.
So I'm going to go ahead
and run that query.
Then after I run that query,
I need to do something
that we call a commit.
And I need to say--
I need to say,
con.commit, which commits
the changes to the database.
If you don't run that
con.commit, then--
it's also curser.commit
will work.
But I want to commit all
the changes to the database.
So if you don't run that, then
the changes are only temporary.
So I must commit the changes
to the database, which
is kind of a nice
failsafe that if you
forget to run that commit, that
it's not actually persisted
to the database.
So it will show up as
though it did change
for the duration of the program,
but it doesn't actually--
it doesn't actually do a
final change to the database
until you say con.commit.
So I want to change that.
And then I'm going to do
the same thing I did up here
and write this same
query down here below.
The only thing I'm going to
change is that instead of--
so this is basically checking
that the change went through.
I am going to instead of saying
results SQL cursor.fetchall,
maybe I'll say, output
results or update results just
to make sure that I'm
not confusing myself.
It would have
worked just to have
results replaced by the update.
But I don't want to do that.
I like to have different
variable names.
So now let's go
ahead and run this.
I'm updating that record,
then I'm rerunning the query
that I did up above just to make
sure that the changes actually
went through.
So I'll go ahead and run this.
And you'll notice that in my
second print statement, which
is my update results, that
Troy Jacobs age is now 33.
So I have written an
SQL query to check
what is their current
age, updated their age,
and then checked that
the update went through.
So pretty cool.
That is program number 1 here.
Now on down here
to program 2, we're
going to add a new winter
product to the winter product
table.
See the below information
about the product.
After you add the product, prove
that you added the product.
So let's go ahead and do this.
So again, I'm going to
copy down this code.
You're in program 2.
And I will say, all right,
let's run my cursor.execute
and I want to add
this new product.
So I'm adding this into
the winter product table.
So if I wanted to, I can pull
up my Overland ERD and data
dictionary and see here that the
prod ID, prod name, category,
price, peak price, quantity,
and description are all part
of my winter product table.
The other thing that
I'm going to check for
is down here in
my data dictionary
that I can see here that
this primary key is not
auto incrementing where
this product ID is.
So because it's not
auto incrementing,
I need to tell it exactly
what primary key to assign
to this new product.
Where in other fields
or when other tables,
you can just ignore that
primary key in your INSERT INTO
statement and it will auto
generate the primary key.
So let's go ahead and do this.
I'm going to say
cursor.execute, and I'll
say insert into winter prod.
And I want to insert
the fields, again,
if we take a look back
at our PowerPoint slide,
I say insert into
the winter prod,
and then I list out
the different field
names which I can capture from
that Overland data dictionary.
I'm going to say prod ID,
prod name, category, price,
peak price, quantity,
description.
And then after that, after
I place all those fields,
I'll say values I want to add in
R are lodge 5 as the product ID.
So that's prod ID
is the first field
I listed, so it'll be the
first value that I listed.
Then the prod name,
which is lodging 5.
You notice that I put it within
the single quotation marks
because it's qualitative data
or string data, if you will.
Then, the next
thing that I'm going
to add in is a category,
which is my third value over
is lodging.
Then the next thing
that I'm going to add in
is going to be my price, which
is 300 peak price, which is 520;
the quantity, which is 30;
and then the exclusive--
and again, within quotation
marks, exclusive yurt lodging.
Now we have to use these
quotation marks because
as a reminder in SQL, you must
include qualitative or string
data within those
single quotation marks.
So now I'm going to go
ahead and have my closing
parentheses of this values.
So I have to have that closing
parentheses of my values.
Then I have the semicolon, which
denotes the end of the query.
And then I have that my query
ends with that double quotation
mark.
So I started with a
opening parentheses,
include the whole query
within double quotation marks,
and then I make sure that
any parentheses I begin,
I end/ and then I have
that beginning and ending
parentheses.
Perfect.
Now what I want to do
is I want to just verify
that the new product was added.
So I'll say cursor.execute,
let's just say,
select star from winter prod.
Then what's going to
bring back to me is--
I'll say query results
equal to cursor.fetchall.
And then I will say for--
it doesn't matter-- for a
in query results, print a.
So now once I run
this, I can see here
that what is output to
me is my query results
and that Lodge 5 is now a winter
product that did not previously
exist.
But once I run my SELECT
star from winter product,
after my Insert
into has ran, then I
can, again, add that lodge five.
Now I'm going to do
best practice here.
We're never generally
going to do updates,
but I want to commit all
these changes to the database.
So I'm going to say, con.commit.
And I am actually--
hold up here.
Don't run that because if I run
this whole program again, then
it's going to insert that
new record [LAUGHS] again.
So I'm going to do a hashtag
and comment out that insert
into cursor.execute.
And the reason I'm
going to do that
is because it will add in
another record of insert
into winter prod.
So I'm going to go
ahead and run this.
And we can see here that--
Oh, that's not--
it did not commit.
Hold on.
We're good.
Just rerun the whole program,
and there we have it.
So once I have said
con.commit now,
it's going to be
persisted to the database.
So we actually need
to comment it out
the timed out so
it didn't actually
commit it to the database.
So when I reran it,
the con.commit you'll
see here that now it's added
that new record into my winter
product table.
So make sure that we commit
changes to the database.
And then we're going to check
that the changes happened.
Awesome.
So, as a reminder, because
I ran this cursor.execute,
I was like, oh, maybe it's
going to try and re-enter
the Lodge 5 field or Lodge
5 record into my winter prod
again.
Actually what it
did is it did not
do that because I did not commit
the changes to the database.
So make sure you commit those
changes to the database,
and then we're going to
make the changes happened.
You'll notice that when we first
ran this without the con.commit,
it looked like the
changes had happened.
But when we reran it,
it actually hadn't fully
committed to the database.
So that's the confusing
part, is that if you just
run the insert into, it's
going and immediately check
that was added to the database.
It's going to look like for
the duration of that program,
that it was added into--
that runtime, if you will, that
it was added into the database.
But when we reran
it, it actually
had not been fully
added to the database.
So just make sure, listen,
here is at that con.commit
so that it is that
change is persisted fully
into the database.
So thank you so much for
working through this with me.
I hope that this
was helpful to you.
Thanks for being
an awesome class.
Take care.